[Music]
[Applause]
so Chris Harrison you said tonight that
you usually have to break up fights in
the past but these guys were a little I
don't know what was what word would you
use to describe these men Zoolander I
feel like we went full Zoolander tonight
there was I think we had a faceoff in a
walk-off in the middle of my show what
the hell happened
you lost total control in all
seriousness tonight was a great example
of why I love this show and I love
hosting at Jason just got it and the way
he articulated and felt his emotions and
expressed him to us he took you on that
right he got emotional up there a few
tears were shed what was that about just
tough you go through a breakup and you
break up and you learn from it and you
move on and you don't have to revisit
over and over and every week and it's
been tough because the story that I led
with her I'm not watching over and over
and I know the way I felt
you know those emotions aren't anything
about what's lingering I saw the glow on
her face today she's happier than I've
ever seen her and that makes me happy
who did you want to see tonight to
really give them maybe some closure that
you weren't fully able to I think the
number one person would be Jason
just because you that was such a strong
relationship and I really was starting
to fall in love with him and so when I
ended things so abruptly I just wanted
to be able to give him a reason why and
then Colton who I don't I don't know if
he intended to go there tonight
but where we went with his virginity and
and the light that we're now gonna shine
on that and mad props to him for putting
his heart out there because it would
have been so easy for him to be like the
glib Cavalier like joke it out and just
walk away and he did and he went there
calling you kinda came to play tonight
like you were not messing around and to
be honest with you I had no agenda
nothing on my mind wouldn't coming in
here other than I was looking forward to
saying hi to Becca and seeing her again
I think some comments caught me off
guard and really triggered something in
me and
but like I spoke my truth tonight
[Music]
[Applause]